hello everyone welcome back for lipstick
diaries I'm Nick from Pixie wave and
today we're going to be talking all
about the only one lipstick from Rimmel
and why you need it in your makeup bag
this spring/summer now there's many
reasons why I'm in love with the only
one lipstick and he's dipped a few I
love the packaging I think it looks
really really sleek and looks nice and
your makeup bag or to use when you're
out and about - I really really like
that it has the band that shows the
color around it makes it easier when
shopping but also if you have quite a
few of these like I did when you're
trying to find your color in your makeup
bag there's nothing more annoying than
having to take all the lids off to find
the right color and while I've got the
lid off it smells amazing they smell so
good that you want to put it on your
lips so let's pop it on our lips and
your bed right let's start with the
nudes and dusky Pink's we've got 700
naughty nude
so I've got 200 it's a keeper and I'm
going to pop it straight on my lips so
as you can see the color that has on the
band is the color that lipstick goes on
it's really really moisturizing you can
probably see the shine that's because
it's got vitamin earrings so it keeps
the lips nourished throughout the day
it's very very vibrant when it comes on
that color loss all day long and it
doesn't break away you notice some
lipsticks you get that kind of breakage
on the side the lips especially when
they're matte they they move a bit and
they break away this one is long-lasting
but moisturizing so it's not going to
get that cracking and it stays on
beautifully then on to the Phoenix I
have got number 100 Pinckney love me
the next thing your mind has an
exaggerated lipliner to go with it so
I'm going to put on them first
exaggerated lipliner is the exact color
of the lipstick it's long-lasting it's
soft it's just going to give you that a
little bit more precision that you might
need when using a slightly bolder color
in that gorgeous
you
then under the peachy cobble tones I've
got peachy beachy exaggerated lip liner
first
followed by pichi pichi the only one
lipstick
Chico
all that's lovely call me crazy
exaggerated lipliner
and call me crazy the only one lipstick
then on to future and bright pink I've
got Pinker punch exaggerated lipliner
and the Sanka in the only one lipstick
and lastly we have got the only one
lipstick in listen up she's a nice color
so there you have my 9 color choices I
think there's one for every skin tone
and how we go to do is choose which
one's right for you take care happy
hunting love you lots
bye bye